we have four fractions written over here
and what I want you to do is think about
which of these fractions are or which of
these are the smallest value which of
these is the largest value in which of
these might be equal and there's two
ways that you could do it you could try
to plot them on a number line or you
could try to depict them visually so
pause the video now and try it on your
own so let's plot these on a number line
so let me give ourselves another little
number line right over here you see I
can draw one see so let's say this is my
number line draw it as straight as I can
so that's my number line that is zero
let's say that this is one and then that
is two so let's first try to plot where
one half is on the number line so we can
split the section between 0 & 1 into two
equal sections so two equal sections and
1/2 would means that I would have gone I
would have gone one of those two equal
sections so if I just go that far I
should be at 1/2 so this right over here
is 1/2 now let's think about two fourths
well to do two fourths we would want to
split the section between 0 & 1 into
four equal sections so let's do that so
0 so that's so it's one equal section
two equal sections
three equal sections and four equal
sections so what happens where do we end
up if we go two out of those four equal
sections well we would end up one so we
go one two equal sections so we end up
right over here two fourths we end up at
the exact same place so at least based
on how we've drawn on the number line it
looks like 1/2 is equal to 2/4 so let me
write that down 1/2 is equal to 2/4 now
what about four eighths well let's split
the the the part of our number line
between 0 & 1 into 8 equal sections
so if we take each of those 4 equal
sections and split them into two so now
we have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 I can't draw it
perfectly
but I'm trying to make them equal
section so now it's eight equal sections
and now we're going to go four of them
starting at zero we're going to go one
two three four so we end up at the same
place again this is also equal to four
eight so 1/2 is equal to 2/4 which is
equal to which is equal to four eighths
now what about three eighths well we've
already split our number line into 8
equal sections let's go three of them
one two three so three eighths is right
over here
three eighths is less than one-half it's
less than two fourths it's less than
four eight it is a smaller number let's
see if that also makes sense when we try
to visually depict or try to visually
draw these fractions so I've done that
right over here and this is one half so
I have the same all these rectangles are
the exact same size and this purple one
over here I split it into two equal
sections and we shaded in one of them so
we see that this is one half now here
I've created in two out of the four
equal sections and you see that this
looks the exact same size as the 1/2
right over here that we started with
rectangles of the same size if you shade
in one half or two forts it looks
exactly the same and that makes sense
because if you took this one right over
here if you took this first one and you
divided each of your two equal sections
into two equal sections so you split it
again then you see that this is equal to
2/4 now what about 4 eighths here I've
split it up where I have this one this
one this one and this one shaded in but
if you rearrange them you could see that
you could get exactly the same amount of
the rectangle shaded in and if you want
to see that divide each of these four
into two so divide those into two and
those in a to notice I now have one two
three four out of the eight equal equal
squares shaded in these two things are
equal so let me make it clear
this is an equal fraction which is an
equal fraction of that which is an equal
fraction of that and here this is three
out of eight you see that it's less than
it's less than this region right over
here this one we've literally filled in
half
the entire rectangle four out of the
eight if we did four out of eight here
we would have also had to fill in this
one right over here which we did in it
we only filled in three out of the eight
so it makes sense that three eighths is
a smaller part of our hole than four
eighths or 2/4 or 1/2 and it's likewise
it's a smaller number